the jurogan experience
you know
i've had conversations with people on
this podcast that were
military people high-level people that
were involved in this and they said
there's nothing about that extraction
that was right no and no one held
accountable once again goes back to that
accountability piece which what
confidence does that give you as the
taxpayer that we're going to do
something right in uh in the next
theater of war not very much confidence
there we have proven that we are unable
to take the lessons of the past and
apply them to the future in a way that
is uh is meaningful but really it's the
responsibility of those leaders to do
that for that e1 e2 e3 that that lower
enlisted person who's going to be
standing the gate guard who's going to
be going out there into these streets or
out there into the mountains and uh and
taking fire and dealing with a car
that's coming up that looks like oh
maybe is it bad suspension or is there a
family in there or is it packed with
explosives right and they're 18 years
old and they're out there looking at
this thing and have to make a decision
and then it pulls up and it detonates or
they shoot and guess what it's full of a
family like these things are so
difficult yeah and they have to live
with that for the rest of their lives
and they're put in that position by
senior level leaders who should have
known better on a few things uh
specifically to iraq disbanding the
iraqi army okay so now you have this
entire the trained up military that's
essentially now an insurgency okay we
have that de-bathification so anyone who
had any job in iraq was a bathist so the
person that emptied the garbage the
people that kept the lights on now
debatification those people don't have
jobs so now we're fighting an insurgency
and we're figuring out how to get the
trash picked up how to keep the power on
we're building up an entirely new
government um so and those
those
lessons and those those senior level
leaders they are responsible for making
those decisions just like we would be at
the tactical level and they made the
wrong decision there and that one those
two things right there looking back at
those two things like
i don't know it's almost unforgivable
that they would make those decisions and
not correct it immediately no he created
that insurgency because of those two two
decisions the
hindsight is always 20 20. but we're
looking back on the uh
afghanistan situation
what is the consensus of what would have
been the correct approach
so we essentially it's not lost on many
people that we essentially spent 20
years replacing the taliban with the
taliban
and well-armed and well-armed yeah with
our stuff yeah yeah now why did they do
that why do they leave behind
all of our [ __ ]
i don't know i mean i know when we left
iraq uh there were
i was at a lower level tactical level so
you just kind of hear things i don't
know how true it is but how much it
costs to bring certain things back
rather than leave it there like the gyms
that went up all over the place so
there's all these gyms all over iraq and
you've seen the videos on youtube of the
iraqis trying to work out they're pretty
funny i think there's quite a few out
there uh but you know rather than pack
all that up and take it home just leave
it um and uh well the gyms are the least
concerned i know i'd use that as a as
the most basic level but then you apply
that to how much does it take to get
this helicopter back and that helicopter
back and this and that and hey did we
think that we were going to turn those
over the to the afghans and leave those
with them why didn't we blow them up
well i think we thought they were going
to remain in place as the army that we
trained up for the last uh 20 years but
that no but nobody on the side of the
people that were over there believed
that was possible they thought that
everyone was going to fold the moment
the united states left well you didn't
even have to think that you could see it
you can see the provinces falling from
january february march april may june
july into august i mean you could watch
it if you put it on the screen and show
the provinces that fall i mean
yeah you don't have to be nostradamus to
figure out that hey this isn't looking
so good and everything is converging
here and you could extrapolate that oh
probably every province is going to fall
um but once again what should they have
done
in that particular situation so you have
a couple options one being hey maybe you
could leave a small force at bagram
perhaps to try to keep this military
keep this intelligence service keep this
government running
maybe after 20 years i don't know how
long you can sustain that but you could
have done that and then if things aren't
working out they're the last people to
leave so that's one
so you could you could have done could
have done that or you get everyone out
and leave bagram and it ends up being
the same thing you see watch the whole
government fall the leader left of
course um but uh but now you're not
leaving from a tactically
disadvantageous position so you had
essentially those two options to draw
down to something a very small force um
left there trying to keep that
government going trying to keep that
military going trying to keep that
intelligence service going and then you
could see how that works out or get
everybody out in a way that makes
sense what would be what would be a way
that makes sense how do you get
everybody out in a way that makes sense
so bagram is there's a lot of standoff
different distance at bagram airfield
it's uh you can be there you can look
out you can see people coming from a
long way off
we control that whole area you control
the airfield it's not that chaos that we
saw people hanging on the side of these
planes as they're taking off you control
that thing
rather than the way we left at the
airfield and essentially in town
so
yeah i don't know why we did that